all right Alicia that's me Alicia
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally uh Midland Texas
and tell me about your family
I am the only girl I got an older
brother and a younger brother my oldest
brother is in Arizona and my youngest
brother is there in Midland
my mom is in Midland and my real dad has
passed away
tell me about your childhood my
childhood
um
um
we weren't very privileged I would say
um
I believe my mom tried her the best she
could to raise us
but we were in a sticky situation should
I say
um
so
growing up as a little girl
my mom was married to this man
that became I guess my stepdad you could
say
and uh started back when I was a little
little girl like as early as I can
remember probably from five to six years
old um
I was
I was uh he was touching me
in places of course that a grown man
should not touch a child
um and me being the age that I was I did
not know
that it was wrong
but I knew it was uncomfortable but I
didn't know it was wrong
so um yeah that went on for a little bit
um it got to the point to where it went
on for years and it got to a point where
I was like tired of him messing with me
so
um I would do whatever I could to try my
best to avoid the situation
um
and so whenever I would go to sleep I
would uh tuck the cup I would start
tucking the covers underneath me my body
completely
to so therefore if
someone was moving the blankets I could
feel it and it would wake me up to know
that somebody was trying to mess with me
um if I wake up in the middle of the
night to have to use a bathroom
instead of going to the toilet I would
just
pee on the floor
sorry
so
um yeah
he was pretty abusive too to
um
to
my mom
thank you
he was pretty abusive to my mom
um
we used to be Catholic and um well my
mom had us going to the Catholic church
because of him
so
whenever we would go to church they
taught us
um if you do the sign of
the sign of the cross and pray
everything will be okay
so that's what I used to do whenever
they would fight
um I could hear him beating her up and I
could hear her screaming a lot
and I would always be in my room when I
was just
always do this the sign of the cross and
pray like Lord let everything be okay
I was always more worried about my mom
was worried about me
sorry
and I don't even want to start this
interview like this
I've been mentally trying to prepare
myself for this interview
for a while
you're doing fine
thank you
okay
so anyways
yeah
yeah so uh I think because of the abuse
that um
how he abused her um
he had a lot of mind control over her
um
they were they drank a lot
and there was drugs involved
I didn't know that of course as far as
the drugs were when I was younger but I
did see them drinking and I knew
the only time that he was happy was when
he was drinking
but I also knew
later on in the nights
at stuff the happiness is going to go
away and he's either going to mess with
me or he's going to fight on my mom
so that was just the reality of my
childhood
I used to to go to school in elementary
and
tell people
that I was adopted
in the back of my mind I'm like who
would adopt who would let these people
adopt somebody but whatever
um
I wasn't always bad
um
yeah it wasn't always bad though
um
my brothers had to fight with him
sometimes too it wasn't as crucial
but um they knew also too Whenever there
was a fight to just stay out the way
to not interfere in anything
so
so yeah I kept quiet about everything
that was going on with me
um like I said I kind of felt like it
wasn't right and I was uncomfortable but
I was also scared I'm scared of
getting hurt or scared of my mom getting
beat up
uh I was just scared so I stayed silent
and so basically that's how I grew up
was just to stay silent and whatever
went on in the house stayed in the house
um
I would say I can't remember exactly how
old I was but when I was in the seventh
grade
we were staying with my stepdad's Mom
and Grandma
um at that point in time I was just like
I think I need to
not I was in the seventh grade I think I
was in the sixth grade I was like I
think I'm going to tell my brother like
what's been going on with me
and so I told him and we ended up
telling my stepdad's aunt and
um
she ended up calling the cops on him
and so
he went to jail
um we were still staying with uh we were
still staying with his his mom and his
grandma
um
yeah he went to jail and there was just
a bunch of different stuff going on
um they had like the crisis intervention
people interviewing me and asking me
what happened
um while
in the sessions where he would mess with
me
I was never penetrated by any means but
I was just touched as a little girl
and so
um all that went on uh he gets he goes
to jail and he gets out
and at first I was um my mom allowed me
to stay with one of my aunts who
who always considered a mom to me
so I was allowed to stay with her and my
cousins
and then a little bit down the line she
was like okay it's time for you to come
home
so I had to go back home to her and my
stepdad and my brothers
um
by the time I was in seventh grade
people realized
I had told a few people what had
happened to me and not really thinking
about the severity of this situation
I told people what happened
and I didn't really have no friends
my mom did try to have a birthday party
for me one time
and nobody showed up
because everybody already knew
who I was living with and I was so hurt
at that time at that time
but I didn't realize people weren't
letting their kids come it wasn't me it
was the situation
but anyways
um
okay so then
um
not too long after that
um
I don't remember where my stepdad had
went to but my mom was at work no I
think he might have been in the house
sleep
and my mom was at work and um I went to
the bathroom and opened the bathroom
door and
um I found the can and it was like bent
and burnt and so
um I believe that's how they like would
smoke whatever drug they were smoking
and stuff and so that scared me because
I remember when all that stuff was when
I would see that before that's whenever
I would be messed with so
um I just walked out the house and I
walked to like a near Elementary School
this was during the summer but there was
people there
elementary school and he didn't know
that I had saw and he didn't know I had
left
and anyways they ended up
I'm sitting in the cops over there and
they picked him up again for I guess the
paraphernalia or whatever was in the
house and uh of course he ended up
getting out again and uh back in the
house with with us so
so
um
we went to court for for all of this
um
I would say I was going I was 14
probably when we went to court for it
and um my mom was there every day with
him
and stuff so I never really knew how my
mom felt about me telling on my stepdad
I just knew she so she was supporting
him still
so
um
we went to court
and he was found guilty
um
he was found guilty and but he just got
five years I think there was some I
don't know if there was some kind of
agreement or whatever
but um he was given five years in prison
okay so then we fast forward he's in
prison actually
um right after he went to prison my mom
sent me with my dad who I hadn't seen in
since I was probably like two
and at this point in time my dad he
lives in Omaha Nebraska
and so
um I went there I was actually really
happy honestly to leave to get away
at so I thought anyways so I'm taking
this Greyhound bus we're going from
Texas it went to I believe Kansas and
Missouri and I'm just like 14 or 15 year
old girl taking this trip alone you know
and um but I'm not even really thinking
too much about it just happy to get away
from Texas
so then I make it to Omaha and I meet my
dad that like I said I hadn't seen since
I was a toddler so this man is like
foreign to me
so all of a sudden now that I see this
man I'm like scared I'm like nervous
because I don't know him
so one night I ended up going to sleep
and I wake up I fell asleep on the couch
and I woke up and he was literally
sitting in a chair right next to me
staring at me
and he could have been doing it because
he couldn't believe that his daughter
was there but I thought it was weird
because of the situation that I just
came out of so
all of a sudden I no longer trust men
I like at all so
um
I was crying and I just told him I
wanted to go back home and so he sent me
back home so I went back home and I
stayed went back home to my mom and my
brothers and my grandma
which is his uh his mom and his grandma
after he goes to prison I ended up uh
getting pregnant with my first child at
the age of 16 years old to the man that
I eventually ended up marrying
um
we ended up having four kids together we
ended up have getting in apartments
it got to a point where every time that
I was pregnant somebody else was
pregnant so I didn't have too much
guidance uh
as far as or self-love like what a woman
should do or accept or not accept
growing up so whatever I was settling
for
a bunch of BS
uh
my ex-husband at one point had ended up
stealing rent money from me I was the
only one working every time that I was
pregnant
and only one working so
I was taking care of everything pregnant
or not and so anyways uh
this guy ends up still in the rent money
from me one day to take somebody to a
prom and I ended up having to live with
my kids in a better women's shelter
um he threatened me that if I ever went
to my mom's house he would get the kids
taken away from me because of the
situation that I dealt with when I was a
kid
so um anyways
a longer story short I ended up having
to move in with my mom with my kids and
he entered turned around well my stepdad
ended up getting out of prison by this
by this point and she ended up taking my
stepdad back
and um
I ended up losing my kids he ended up
taking them from me
uh once that happened I tried to commit
suicide because I was without my kids
and I felt like I was just without
everything
so um
so after that it was just hard for me to
get my kids back but I've always been
a big part of my kids lives I have four
boys by the way
um so you lost your kids for what reason
exactly for what reason he well he got
them because
my stepdad had got out of prison and I
was staying with my mom and she took him
back in the house so I had my kids
around sex offender yes
and um
so yeah that was that was the biggest
thing
um and I felt like it was kind of a way
to control the situation as well yes my
kids should not have been but I didn't
have anywhere else to go like I
literally got kicked out of everywhere
because of the relationship I was in
with him every uh batter women's shelter
Hood everything like because I was
letting this guy just be in my life and
whatever
so uh
there was a point in time when me and
him got back together for a little bit
but it didn't work out and he kept the
kids
and he ended up putting me on child
support as soon as he got the boys like
it didn't matter the fact that um
it didn't matter that I was always the
one taking care of him and taking care
of my kids none of that stuff mattered
as soon as he got the kids he took
advantage of that situation
and so I started paying a little over
900 a month to him and still taking care
of my kids as far as still providing for
them
so anyways um
I can talk about right now uh
what happened recently with my mom which
made me kind of really reach out to you
and this is the hardest
part of the whole interview for me
okay when I was a little girl and uh my
stepdad was messing with me
I have the memory of
my mom being there to
and my mom touching me too
and I've carried that with me like
forever
and I never was really close with my mom
for that reason but she was still my mom
and I still loved her
and I felt sorry for her because I don't
I never understood why she kept this man
around and I never understood why she
would hurt me
foreign
very recently I reached out to her and I
told her I wanted to talk to her
and so she came over to she came over to
my house and we talked
and I told her like Mom I didn't tell on
you because I loved you but I remember
what you did
and she was like what are you talking
about
and I said you will be there with him
sometimes uh when he was touching me and
all of a sudden I was the devil and I
was a liar and I make all this stuff up
in my head
it wasn't pretty it wasn't pretty at all
and I feel bad for her because
I don't understand where her whole mind
came is she did tell me
that
her mom she had problems growing up too
with her dad and him
touching on them
and the mom always my granny always told
them to keep everything quiet so
um so they never they were taught to
never tell and so to them
this kind of stuff that went on in a
household was normal and you don't tell
and so
so yeah so I asked I ended up asking her
in the same conversation
how did you keep this man around like
how did you pick him over me I mean even
whenever he was in prison she would make
me go visit him and everything with her
and she was like well when we went to
court they they only said that you had
however
big of a terror on your hymen or
whatever so basically
she was trying to tell me that nothing
ever happened to me not with her not
with him and that this everything like
that's gone on in my life
has been a lot like I believed a lie
like the whole time basically that's
what she was telling me like
all of this was a lot even though he was
convicted and he went to prison and
I have all of my memories
apparently she's trying to make it seem
as though I was delusional or I am
delusional for making this stuff up and
so needless to say I haven't talked to
my mom in the past couple of months
um for this reason
was your adult life been impacted by all
of this oh
my adult life has been so
hard like so hard
um
I didn't realize how bad the molestation
affected me until I was about 34.
um
but I think that if I had like a mom
that was actually a mom uh
I would have done things so much more
different like I would not have stayed
with a man that was taking advantage of
me uh
uh
from the beginning
um
because of the situation I was in with
my ex-husband
I've been having to work in
like really hard to be able to pay bills
I don't qualify for any kind of uh
assistance I have to have a job to make
enough money to make sure that I pay him
his money even though well I'll get to
that later but anyways as far as the
molestation goes
um
I didn't realize how much it affected me
until I was about 34.
um I was in a situation
um
I don't really know how to put this but
anyways I was I I was able to see two
people interact with each other sexually
and when I saw them interact with each
other
I could see like passion like a
connection
and so
I realized when I saw that that I've
never had that ever in my life because
once he touched me when I was a kid
um I had a feeling
I had a feeling and that feeling is the
feeling that I felt that I was supposed
to feel growing up as a woman so
whenever anything sexually happened I
didn't think to reach for a Feeling
more than this
if that makes any sense
so yeah I didn't know sexually
um I didn't know that
whenever you are having sex there is
something there could be something
beautiful behind it I never
I didn't know that until
I was watching two other people be
intimate with each other
and it was beautiful and I realized I
hadn't been in a situation to where it
was ever beautiful
it was just to do it
um also just uh
watching other females and being seeing
them like go to lunch with their mom or
just doing mom and daughter things like
I don't know what that what that is like
I really honestly don't know what that
feeling is
and I wish that I did I just feel like
that I don't I didn't know what
what it was to have a mom or dad
honestly
so it affected the way I raised my boys
as well
foreign
I make sure that uh I keep my boys close
every day I make sure
a conversation with them each and every
day I make sure to tell them I'm sorry
every day
for the times that I or the times that I
was still learning
foreign
right now my boys are older so they
completely unjust I don't I wouldn't say
completely understand but they do
understand that they have a mom that
loves them dearly and would do anything
for them
and to me that's
all that matters because
I don't want my kids to grow up
and be in their 30s and wonder why
their mom didn't love them
I would never do that to my kids
literally on like
my social medias it's really all I ever
post is my kids
I don't really post nothing else my kids
like my oldest son is 21 and I post him
like he's a one-year-old still
like I'm proud of every little step that
he takes like just that's how I am with
all of them and I'm sure people are like
why did she post her boys so much
but if they only knew
oh I opposed to my voice so much
and I really was not intending on crying
this much during this interview so I
apologize
have you seen a therapist anything like
that
I have not seen a therapist
I did back in the day when I um
tried to commit suicide one time
and I was diagnosed with PTSD
and I was given some medication for her
but I had to stop that but that was a
long time ago
today is just I don't know I guess
speaking about it is really hard I have
actually
been really good and like even when I
had the conversation with my mom even
though it was a tough one
um it made me feel better it made me
feel like a lot of weight was lifted off
my shoulders
to actually let her know and finally get
that off of my chest
um it made me feel a lot better
and even though we're not talking now
um I do what my mom to know I love her I
want the best for her of course
but um I just need I just need my time I
just definitely need my time
Alicia what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned out of
all of this
[Music]
I was I would say
I think the greatest lesson I've taken
from it is to be the best mom that I can
be
it's a great one
all right Alicia thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you thank you very much